let's go uh next to oh let's go to our
old old friend isa from london issa how
are you
i'm good how are you i'm doing well and
what what's going on all coveted
guidelines are being ended there is that
right
yeah that's right yeah they they
scrapped everything
uh but you know i don't know if you keep
up with uk politics much there's
you know much much bigger issues with
our government so
right now
a whole whole lot going on you know yes
indeed and i mean are you referring to
the boris johnson coveted party stuff or
what specifically yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know
there's new new things from the past
that you know get brought up every day
but today's topic i guess yeah is
johnson yep
um but go ahead yeah sorry
um yeah i was gonna say this is a
thought i was having um aaron rodgers
said his stuff about
uh people brewing against green bay
because of his vaccine status yes i
think
i feel like what happened to rogers is
the same thing that happened to rogan
which rogan happened on a much larger
scale and what i mean is he came out and
he said all his stuff right about
vaccines and how he wouldn't take them
and how he encourages young people not
to get them
and then he caught covered
and
everyone clowned him for that so badly
that it kind of led him to snap
if you understand where i'm coming from
it basically clipped him over the edge
and ever since then
his
whole persona his personality has been
covered
leftists woke mob cancel culture
mainstream media cnn and even even the
guests he brings on his shows
they're just people that he can circle
jerk with about how right he is to
reaffirm himself
so
yeah i was just wondering what you think
about that well i ended up saying you
know when i talked about aaron rodgers
the nfl football player saying people
were rooting against us because of my
vaccine status i gave and i said that's
true to some degree i gave it more
thought
i think that there's actually more to it
i think people some people were rooting
against aaron rodgers because the entire
covid thing
made him look like a know-it-all prick
and that's what a lot of people were
kind of reacting to more so than the
fact that he's unvaccinated per se
yeah
in terms of the rogan stuff i mean
listen
i know the guy a little bit
and i believe him when he says
he's not trying to spread disinformation
he believes the stuff that the guests
say
i i do believe that i i don't think he's
trying to spread this information i just
think he is and i think part of it is
we know that since he's moved to texas
at least somewhat he hangs out with the
with the wacky republican governor greg
abbott you know he's in he's in a circle
where i think what's going on around him
is very reactionary and radical and even
without bad intentions i think he's just
been captured by a lot of the stuff i'm
not excusing anything he's done i think
the stuff that's gone out on his show is
terrible but i believe him when when he
says he's not malicious in trying to
spread this information i think it's
coming from a place of ignorance
yeah no of course yeah that's fair
enough i mean you've you've been on his
show twice you you know him so yeah and
that's fair it just seemed to me
that ever since the whole kobe thing
happened his ego i guess has been
wounded deeply so it's possible i can't
speak to that but it's certainly
possible that that's what's going on
yeah
yeah
oh yeah cool
all right lisa from london thank you so
much for the call great to hear from you
again of course
if you or someone you know is into
science astronomy space this is for you
our sponsor under lucky stars creates
beautiful personalized star maps showing
the unique position of the stars in the
sky
at the place and time chosen by you
under lucky stars is a great way to
remember an important moment someone's
birthday wedding day your engagement you
give them a time and a location that you
want to commemorate they show you
exactly how the stars and constellations
looked in a spectacular super high
quality print it's a completely
personalized gift experience you can
customize it into a ton of designs you
can read on their website how all the
star maps are scientifically accurate
this is the one i got showing the time
of my birth in buenos aires argentina
the quality of the material and the
print they're fantastic i was really
impressed under lucky stars is perfect
for valentine's day and right now
they're giving my viewers 10 off when
you click the link below and enter the
code d pacman